well residents of this city have been
asked to make fire bombs to help
neutralize russian forces pictures have
emerged of people queuing for guns with
the government saying thousands of
weapons
have been handed out members of
parliament have also
armed themselves uh among them slav
ukraine's youngest mp last night he
shared this image
of him carrying an ak-47
on the streets of kiev and he joins me
now
well thank you very much for being with
us first of all can you believe
while you're walking around the streets
there can you believe what is happening
to your city and your country
as i'm talking with you there's there
are explosions in distance basically
happening i'm trying to overrun nikola
curfew and sorry and they held the
soldiers
and do you do you
i don't think you can hear me we can't
hear you now
sorry i'm just again i mean
my documentation basically
so here we are the youngest ukrainian
mps wandering around the streets of kiev
you're back with us
okay i just wondered
are you do you feel safe yourself do you
feel that you and your family are safe
i will be joining with the fighting for
here because there's no other choice now
we have fought in kiev today we have had
russian courage in the north of the city
we have russian columns
heading for the north and for the
eastern part of town
and we
have just underground this is our
capital which we cannot give up my
family i am from the western ukraine so
my family is there
and even though
every city in ukraine and my hometown as
well were hit
by uh
by missiles from russia
and different kinds of attacks
still they're safe for them here but i'm
staying in the capital because that's
the only honorable thing to do
for a person who wants to his country to
survive this onslaught
and if the russians come into the
capital would you stay in the capital or
would you then leave
they are in the capital today they'll be
fighting in north the city and they're
dropping rockets and you guys hear the
explosions as i'm walking
to the center of town to the area where
the presidential
administration made an appeal today
to the citizens of ukraine showing the
presidency here prime minister is here
leadership is here to defend our capital
not allow russians to win
no matter what
and if
the russians do come in and put in
another government and remove president
zielenski how would the people
of kiev and the people of ukraine react
to that
it's not about the government it's not
about zalensky uh
russians mr putin made a long hour-long
speech that the whole world can see
available to you ever on every social
media that features about his
firm belief that ukraine is one nation
he creates another state
and that
he wants to take over ukraine he wants
ukraine to be a part of russia
ukrainians by every measure every poll
don't agree with that statement so we
are going to fight
with everything we got to the very end
to keep our nation away from him
and do you see
a long war of resistance
if they come in and they topple the
government do you see a war of
resistance happening
i was born
after the soviet union i only know
ukraine
and there are millions like me
would not
even dare to presume anything else but
independent ukraine and we will fight
to keep that independent ukraine a
reality no matter
the putin we're putting puts on the
table no matter what he puts against us
again
for the last two days ukraine has been
fighting a war on every border with
russia
from the south the north the east
and we've seen plenty of their
instruments plenty of their weaponry we
captured many of their prisoners
we destroyed very many as well and we
shown okay um is that your weapon you
have with you now love yes
yes
it's the ak
basically i'm i'm you know why i'm
talking walking because i have to get
home before curfew to then in the
morning go north of kiev
to the area where
some russian columns are and one of my
teammates sitting in the fence to try
and help him one with the other slav
we've got to leave it there uh st try
and stay safe and thank you for being
with us we've got
uh you very much
on the program
and all i can say is thank you very much
indeed around us several explosions uh
the fighting continues here
with a vengeance
[Music]
did you know the universe formed into
the shape of a pringle's chip and humans
evolved for one reason only
pringles with opposable thumbs to pop
it's tongues are shaped to fit them and
t-spots just to taste them
you were made for pringles i am charles
darwin and i fully endorse this theory
man popping
[Music]
borders can be useful
but not always
[Music]
glass ceiling classic border you're not
listening to me no you're not listening
political borders very popular these
days
sometimes the borders are within
[Music]
but when we see beyond borders we see
opportunity everywhere
there's one
[Music]
what if people with type 1 diabetes have
the power to manage their condition
without pricking their finger